- But one thing I love
that you talk about,
and I think it was actually
a couple of years ago
maybe even that you first
started talking about it,
people were like, "Oh my gosh,
2020 is going to be the detriment of it."
Or like, "It's gonna,
everything is horrible.
It's the apocalypse" and I loved,
that you said, it takes some
times that deconstructing,
that blowing up a things,
to actually sort out all the
crap that's actually wrong.
Are you hopeful or are
you still kind of like,
Oh my gosh, like what's happening?
- Two things, I mean, I
used the word apocalypse,
apocalypse means uncovering.
- Yeah, right?
- So in terms of
what this time is doing,
none of this, none of this is happening.
None of this injustice and
inequality is new at all, right?
Which is why, my activist
friends aren't the ones saying,
"Oh my God, 2020 is the worst."
They're actually feeling hopeful,
because this is, all of this inequality
has been going on for a very long time.
It's just that now people
are finally seeing it
because of the apocalypse
uncovering of COVID.
As to whether I'm hopeful or not,
I heard Stacey Abrams say the other day,
someone said, "Are you hopeful?"
And she said, "I am neither
hopeful nor pessimistic.
I am determined."
- Oh,
- I love that so much.
Because, as someone who's sober,
I rely on what I can control.
And I know what I can't
control is outcome.
So pessimism and optimism
are relying on outcome.
But determinism, being determined,
that all has to do with our input.
How we're showing up, right?
So what I know is I am
determined over the next weeks
to get to every single
untamed woman I know
to refuse being gaslit,
to know what she knows,
feel what she feels,
and to show up at the polls, November 3rd.
- Amen, Alicia,
(applause)
How are you feeling about everything
like voting and everything?
I know that,
everybody always gets
frustrated with people
in the music and the music
world, and the art world.
And they're like just,
you know, be artistic.
And I'm like,
"Yes, but also like I'm not
pushing my views on you.
But you have to realize how,
I think, because we've traveled,
we see how lucky we are,
how fortunate we are,
to be able to vote."
I don't know, I feel like
it's kind of your duty
as an American citizen to say
something like that, you know?
- I mean, it is.
It is all of our responsibility.
It's all of our opportunity.
And definitely it is.
It is, it's something that we all should
feel really actually excited
and passionate about, you know?
We can all learn so much more.
I think that's one thing
that I think about a lot.
You don't have to know it all.
I think that's one of the
things that feels intimidating.
You're like, "Whoa, I'm not
sure and how about this, and"
It's okay that you don't know it all.
And it's okay to actually
start to learn more.
I think that's something
that I'm asking my friends
and family and also just
you know, anybody who's
connecting with me.
I'm like, let's take a moment to actually
dig into the parts that we don't know.
Let's dig into the parts of the ballot
that maybe we are a little
bit insecure about or,
the names that we're not so clear about,
or the policies that maybe
don't make perfect sense or,
that we didn't take the time
to look into enough yet.
It's okay, it's all a growing process,
and it's all a part of
actively being a human being.
You know, and actively being
able to be a participant
in what this whole thing looks
like, you know what I mean?
This is up to us.
This is not thing where it's like,
"Oh, we're gonna hope that that one guy
or woman does the thing."
No, one person can't do
anything all by themselves.
We all need to show up.
We have to show up for our families,
for our own kids
for our sisters and brothers,
for our communities.
Because if we're not showing up,
no one else is gonna be like
"Oh, hey, what's happening in your spot?
'Cause I care so much about you."
No, we have to care about our selves.
We have to care about
ourselves enough to show up.
So it's less about
that they're gonna do all this stuff,
and what, and we gotta show up for us.
You know, less about them, more about us.
And let's learn about what we can
so that we can align with people that have
similar beliefs and thoughts.
But man, this is for us.
We gotta do this.